the left does not have this clarity i
said this i thought the chunk uber tweet
was gonna be the dumbest thing i saw on
the internet for the past several days
no
sean penn you know that brilliant actor
sean penn
he actually is an excellent actor but
he's not a brilliant
person uh he had the dumbest thing i've
seen on the internet in a long time i've
read the new york times recently i've
read the washington post recently
sean penn takes the cake he said quote
evangelical
leaders should themselves be impeached
by the vatican
wait for it if they themselves don't
follow nikki haley's lead
and clearly state they should not have
followed
satin into the bowels of hell but
perhaps they're too busy at sex parties
there are many things wrong with this
tweet first of all
evangelical leaders probably will not be
impeached by the vatican
because they are not catholic they don't
recognize the authority of the
of the pope or the vatican uh sean penn
doesn't understand that there's
something called protestantism
they're in catholicism they're different
uh
he then talks about how great nikki
haley is he then misspells satan's name
to satin which makes you know i suppose
satan is the slippery sort of figure so
the images are similar but satin much
comfier than
the father of lies and then he gets in
this jive at sex parties
the reason i mention it is is not really
to probe
sean penn's deep religious and political
thoughts or the lack thereof
but to show as ronald reagan once said
it's not what people don't know that
gets them into trouble
it's what they know for certain that
just ain't so
sean penn doesn't know anything people
during the especially during the bush
administration they tried to make sean
pan out to be this
intellectual leader of the left because
he's a good actor so he kind of
looks really intelligent he's got this
kind of squishy smoldering face you know
and it's really it seems like he's deep
in thought
i think all that is going on in his head
is the whistling
going from ear to ear i don't think
there's a whole lot going on in there
but he he looks that way and i think
this is true of the left when when the
left is talking about
any topic american history
the nature of the regime american
government civics
the cultural and moral considerations
they just
not only don't know what they're talking
about but they know so many things that
aren't so
and they're they're offering this kind
of narrative you know
you'll notice they always use this term
narrative that crazy congress lady that
we discussed at the beginning of the
show
who's calling for a truth commission
does this the 1619 project does this
they say we need to reframe the
narrative and
in part the reason that they do this is
because the way we tell stories affects
how politics
will play out but also because
the left seems to have embraced a
radical skepticism
about objective truth you know when they
talk about um intersectionality or
you know lived experiences that's
another term
they use what they're suggesting is
or my truth or your truth or the you
know
this is how i feel what they're saying
is that we can't rely on objective
reality there may be there isn't any
such thing as objective reality
or objective truth it's all just a
social construct
you know there's no men or women it's
all socially constructed
and so the narrative is everything
a lot of this comes from what some kind
of radical academics during the mid to
late 20th century
dairy daw in particular uh and and some
of derrida's followers will
will claim that this is not really what
he meant but he said there's nothing
outside the text
it's a very famous line in this kind of
radical academic movement there's
nothing
outside of the text and what this has
been at least interpreted to mean for
many years is
it's just uh it's all words words words
to use a hamlet's line when he was
feigning madness
it's all just kind of stories and
there's there's no fundamental reality
that it's connected to
so if we change the words we can change
the culture this is
the fundamental premise of political
correctness if we just redefine
reality then reality actually will
change that that is what
we're up against here and and it's why
we kind of argue things a little bit
differently but so what conservatives do
is they say no
these american figures did this they
said this they meant this
we it's not just all being made up in
our minds every day we can't just
redefine history
however we want we're referring to some
reality the left
broadly speaking isn't really playing
that game they're playing a different
game a game of narrative
construction which is why they try to
blot out history tear down statues
rewrite historical and literary
documents
that have been so influential to our
tradition and the result
is uh pretty unpleasant
unfortunate for a lot of people if you
enjoyed that video be sure to hit the
subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we have got the absolute top
content
out there